[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOEL KALMANOWICZ:
Hello, everyone.
How are you all doing today?
I see some smiles, nods.
Hey, thanks for responding.
I like that.
I can hear you.
You don't have a microphone,
so that says something.
All right.
Hey, welcome.
Welcome to I/O. This is day two.
Welcome to this session.
And to all of you out
there on the livestream
and watching the recording,
thank you for joining us.
My name is Joel Kalmanowicz
I'm a product manager on Google
Maps APIs, and my
goal is to help
you bring your users the
world by making it your own,
however works best for you.
Now, maps may help us
understand and access the world,
and they're an incredibly
important part of our lives.
We all have really busy lives.
So how important
are maps really?
Being part of Google, I like to
look at Search for my answers.
And if we look at the
entirety of human interest
through queries on Google,
it turns out that about one
in every five searches
is location related.
That's pretty significant.
And on mobile, that number
is almost one in three.
And mobile is growing faster.
People doing
location-related searches
need a variety of
answers and services
to match their needs provided
through a whole ecosystem
of products and developers.
That's where you come in.
So, we actually have a very
large and diverse community
of developers with over
2 million apps and sites
using our Google
Maps APIs every week.
And here you are.
I'd actually like to ask
you all if you could just
raise one hand with me.
You know, if you're at
I/O raise your hand.
Come on, seriously, all
of you in the audience.
I'm talking to you.
Yeah.
Go on, stick your hand up.
OK.
Thank you.
That's almost everyone.
No, no, keep it up.
There we go.
Keep it here.
Now lower your hand if you've
never used Google Maps APIs.
I only see a few hands go down.
That's impressive.
Thank you very much for coming.
I hope you learn something
new and useful today.
For those of you who
didn't raise your hands,
the people who did are
your new best friends.
Go talk to them and
ask them how you
want to use Google Maps APIs.
Now, if you have
more questions, you
can come to our
office hours, as well,
or stick around for
the Q&A after the show.
So, we have a very
engaged community.
All of you watching, as well.
We really appreciate it.
In fact, I'd like to show
you what level of engagement
we've been seeing from
all of you out there.
Today I'm excited to
share that we serve over
two billion maps to
users every single day
through Google Maps APIs.
That is absolutely amazing.
It reinforces how,
when we work together,
we can bring so much
for so many people.
And for those of you
who want to join us,
or all of you who
already know quite a bit
and who'd like to learn more, we
have a rich collection of APIs
that give you
solutions people trust.
From Markers to Elevation,
Places to Street View,
and more, these are
all icons from our APIs
that you can build on.
And we'll dig into a few of
the visual ones later on.
But first, I would like
to change gears and share
something new with you.
As we looked at how a
consumer and developer
communities use Google Maps
and our APIs, we saw a gap.
Different developers
have different needs.
And different use
cases for users
involve different
needs, as well.
They have different goals.
In fact, sometimes existing
Google Maps apps features
can serve users really
well, and you don't always
want to have to integrate all
of those services directly
inside of your app.
So to make those moments
easier, we're now
introducing Google Maps URLs.
We've heard your feedback.
Mapping is sometimes not
a core part of your app,
but you need the functionality
to complete your user journey.
In these cases, you don't want
to have to get an API key.
You don't want to have to learn
all these different libraries.
And few people like
having to duplicate
similar work across platforms.
So Maps URLs offer a simple,
straightforward solution
that work for you and
your users anywhere.
We've focused on a
few key use cases
that we think will
have you covered.
The most common mapping needs.
I'm going to take you through
a few complete code examples
across all four of these to
show you just how simple Maps
URLs really are.
We'll start where everything
started at Google--
with Search.
To trigger a search,
we just build
a URL in this format with a
query parameter of our choice.
The URL launches Google
Maps and instructs
it to perform the
search immediately.
Now by including
an area to search,
you're going to show what's
around a particular place.
I've gone for sushi
near our conference,
but you can see
how this would be
useful to find schools near a
new home that your user may be
interested in, or restaurants
near a hotel they have just
booked.
You can also leave out
any reference to location
and just put sushi, for
example, to let the end user
search for places near them.
And you don't have to ask
for or use the location
permission to do this.
In your own app, you don't
need to worry about it.
You can delegate that
work to Google Maps.
And then you can direct people
to their nearest stores,
service providers,
parks, or anything else
you can think of, without having
to think about how you do it.
If it's on Google
Maps, you can find it.
And just like searching
in Google Maps,
if your query returns one top
result, you get a little more.
Here I've referred
to a venue by name,
and I've got a nice pin that's
gone on the map with a label;
a place sheet at the bottom
that shows Reviews, a Directions
button, and a Street
View thumbnail;
and, of course, I can
swipe the place sheet up
to get more information.
If you want to showcase
a particular store
or a particular location
or service provider,
this gives users a lot of
that info that we already
have on Google Maps.
And if you're handling place
IDs already from our other APIs,
like an order
complete, you can also
use them to target
the place directly.
If you want to learn
more about this,
I really recommend checking
out our next location and maps
talk, on A Sense of Place,
tomorrow morning at 9:30
right here.
And for those of
you watching online,
you can find us by
name, A Sense of Place.
Another classic use case
on a map is Directions.
We all need to get
where we're going.
And we're here to help
your users find their way.
But we've also taken
this a step further,
and we've included
waypoints that you can route
uses how ever you need to.
You can also use this yourself.
Say, if you work at the
nearby NASA Ames facility,
and you need to drop the kids
off at childcare, go to work,
grab them on the way home,
and that's one URL, actually.
It's as simple as putting
in the waypoints you
need as a query parameter,
under the waypoints parameter
there, separated by a pipe.
And then you're good to go by
the travel mode of your choice.
Waypoints are great for anyone
with very complicated, or even
simple but just little bit extra
more routing needs than what
you would get by default. But
if you're feeling creative,
you can also use them
to draw something.
Maybe a little something
that looks like I/O.
Now, let's do something
more practical.
Here we've kept the
directions endpoint, shown
in blue on the first
line of code there,
but we've changed
the parameters.
The destination is now a
collection of Android statues.
If you haven't seen
them, I recommend them.
And since they're a
short bike ride away,
I've changed the
travel mode to suit.
But more importantly,
I've added the parameter
to start navigation immediately.
This is really handy,
especially for situations
where you want your users
to be able to get somewhere
without having to
touch their device.
For example, if you're using
our Speech APIs or the Assistant
SDK.
Now we've also dropped
the origin parameter,
so Maps will just start
navigating from wherever
your user is in the real world.
Again, this is
another example of not
needing to worry about
location permissions.
Wherever the user
is, we'll handle it.
Now, the day has been
getting a little long, right?
So you might be more
concerned about local traffic
and checking out our Androids.
I wouldn't blame you.
So here under the
at endpoint, now
I've got a map and
a layer of my choice
at the zoom level we want.
And you may notice that this
screenshot was taken before I/O
because all the traffic lines
are green, or almost all
of them.
Yes.
But you can leave
the center blank.
And again, it'll just
focus on user location.
Or, as I've done
here, you can specify
a lat/long coordinate
to focus the camera
exactly where you need it.
Now, this is great
for scenarios where
you want to give users the sense
of an area around a business,
or a service provider, or
even a piece of real estate
that they might
be interested in.
And we can dig a little
deeper into this use case.
If we go from a
top-down view, we
can switch to our
immersive imagery.
With Street View,
you can offer people
the experience of
really being there,
whether it's at
the Grand Canyon,
a store they've never been
to, or a potential new home.
Street View is our panoramic
imagery, or pano for short.
And so we've changed the
map action parameter,
on the second line
there, to match,
signaling that we want a pano
at the viewpoint location
that we've entered a
lat/long coordinate.
You can also
specify the pano ID,
if you already have it from
other Street View APIs,
similar to the place ID that
we called out a few slides ago.
Now, I just showed
you an iOS mark
and that switched
over to iOS here,
because this is all
platform-agnostic.
This is available
on any platform.
For example, Google Maps is
a popular mapping app on iOS,
but there are devices out there
that don't have it installed.
For any device that does
not have a Google Maps
native app installed,
the URL will
be handled by Google Maps
web apps in a browser.
And while not all
platforms support
every bit of
functionality, there's
one specific example I
would like to call out here.
Navigation doesn't
work on web maps.
Sorry.
What happens if you try
and start navigation
and your user's using a web map?
We simply gracefully
ignore that parameter,
show them directions,
and it works anyway.
We didn't want to make
it more complicated.
We wanted to be able to offer
this across every platform.
So this graceful
fallback has allowed
us to do so and make it
available everywhere.
Speaking of available.
Maps URLs are actually
live right now.
And you can give them a shot
right after this session.
I don't see anyone looking
down at their phones yet,
so thanks for waiting.
There's no setup
necessary, and we've
tried to make the
syntax so simple
that you can literally type
one of these up yourself.
What you've been seeing on
the slides is all you need.
Now one other
parameter that I'd like
to call out that I
haven't mentioned yet
but you've been seeing, is
this first one called API.
This is mandatory for
these URLs to work,
and it functions as our
versioning system for the API.
Today we're launching version 1.
And, of course, you can
enter your own values
for all of these
other parameters.
That's kind of the point.
So if you want to find a dive
bar instead of a coffee place,
or if you have your own business
or a customer's business,
you can just enter
enough for an exact match
and you'll get that Places
sheet that I mentioned before.
And yes, I do have
a link for you
with documentation at
the end of the session.
Got one more example
for you, another one
of these navigation cases.
Some of you may have to get
to the airport to go home.
Again, this is
really easy, though.
And since it's just a URL,
you can use any standard URL
constructing library to
build these and handle things
like sanitizing input
values or dealing
with escaped characters.
You don't have to worry about
that, and neither do we.
So let's take a step back.
We've had a good look
at how Maps URLs can
work for you and
some of the things
that you can use them for.
This is great for getting our
primary Google Maps consumer
use cases working for you and
your users quickly and easily.
But how does this relate to
the rest of our Maps APIs?
All those of you who've
raised your hands
are pretty familiar with
the other ones we've already
got out there today.
There's a trade-off
between the simplicity
of delegating to another
app all this work
and the power of building and
customizing something yourself.
I'd like to help you get a sense
of how we can decide what to do
when we face this trade-off.
So I'm going to walk you
through some of our deeper APIs
and what they can offer
you beyond Maps URLs.
When you need that power of
flexibility, when you really
need to take it to the level of
building a map into your app,
that's when we
recommend our Maps APIs.
So, you might remember
those little logos
I showed you at the beginning.
Well, here they all are expanded
out to our range of APIs
across the four major
platforms we've got support on.
We'll see how just
a few of these
can take you above and
beyond a regular map.
Now let's begin with one
of the most useful things
that you can do on a map,
which is something out.
You can drop markers
with Maps URLs.
Using our Maps URLs, you
can just get one out there,
but it has to be a search
result of some kind.
And it'll either be a
single marker or a range
of results via query.
And it only will show you
existing places or just
a lat/long pin.
If you want any interaction
with your data on the map
beyond just putting
a single point down,
you want to customize
the markers,
you need our Maps APIs.
So, here we're looking at
Italian restaurants in Rome.
I'm going to start with some
public data to keep it simple.
We took the metadata
about the restaurant,
and we actually used
the rating to adjust
the contrast of the marker pin.
The brighter, the
better the rating.
And for the very
hottest places to eat,
we put some subtle
animating steam on top.
And this is all just using our
publicly available Google Maps
APIs.
But I did mention visualizing
your own data, as well.
So let's have a look at
what we can do with that.
Let's say, if you got a high
ratio of markers per area,
you can cluster them to
clean up your UI while still
showing useful
information to the user.
Last time that I
moved I actually
found this personally really
helpful on the real estate
site that I was using, because
at a low level of zoom I
could get a broad sense of how
many properties were available
in a given location.
And when I zoomed
in higher I could
see exactly where they
were and tap on the marker
to get more information.
Clustering is part
of the util library
that we maintain on GitHub for
our Google Maps SDK for iOS.
And then we have a
similar clustering library
in the util library for
JavaScript and Android.
Now speaking of Android, here
you can see another case.
If you want to visualize
something more granular
than a place, something that's
more about the data on the map,
heat maps are a
great way to do this.
So let's say, if you want to
look at something like housing
prices, or sea level
changing, or rainfall,
or anything like that
that can be very granular.
It's more about the
map than a place.
These can be really
easy to generate.
Just plug a data set
in, like a JSON array,
and you're good to go.
We will do all the
rendering for you.
Heat maps are available
in Android and JavaScript.
Another useful feature of our
Maps API is camera animations.
Now these are a
great way to show off
a particular place of
interest to your users
from different
perspectives, whether it's
3D buildings like we have here
or local satellite imagery.
Those same use cases that I
mentioned before for Maps URLs,
for giving people the sense
of what an area is like,
now you could take
them on a little tour
instead of just giving
them a top-down view.
Speaking of top
down, ground overlays
offer an unlimited
customization option for you
by covering the
base map completely.
So here we see an example
of a historical map
of a modern satellite view.
We've got the ground overlay
and the historical map
as pasted straight onto
the base map there.
It's attached to the base
map and will rotate with it.
Now this can be
really fascinating
if you love history.
I have some friends who like
looking at old maps of cities.
Personally, I'm more of
a fan of hiking, though.
So I think it would
be great to be
able to see hiking trails
like this in an app
without having to
deal with the paper.
We can also look
towards the future.
I recently read
about some projects
using Google Maps to visualize
sea-level rise projections.
It's really important to
think about how our planet is
changing, but it
can be hard when
it's on such a large scale.
Personally, being
able to see how
places that I knew would be
changing right there on the map
helped me connect with that.
And additionally, for
those who have the data,
they can just use
the ground overlay
to do this and just
take their visualization
and put it on maps.
But I've also seen
some implementations
where they used
our Elevation API
to calculate shoreline
changes dynamically, directly
on our maps.
Now coming back to the present.
We also have ephemeral
events, things
that don't last a long time,
like this very conference.
And a ground overlay can be
used to put localized geodata
in the form of a
venue map directly
on a Google Map in our app
that we've provided you.
Ground overlays have
a range of use cases.
But if you want to
customize the base
map itself, at scale,
that's another story.
Styling lets you
choose your own color
scheme for the Google Maps
that you get from our APIs.
And we brought this to
mobile platforms last year.
It's proven to be a
popular way to customize
the visuals to suit your needs.
You're going to
write custom JSON,
or generate your
own styles easily,
with our online WYSIWYG wizard--
say that three times fast--
and export them from there.
This is a great tool to
help you quickly iterate
and get a feel for
how your style will
look right there on the map.
Now however you get
your inspiration
for a styling scheme, the
implementation is the same.
Now here I'm going to show
you a JavaScript example.
I'm initializing a new
map object at the top.
And then all I have
to do is provide
the style property, which is a
collection of sub-properties.
And any that I specify
override the default.
So first I'm going to
clear out the map a bit.
I want it to be clean.
I'm going to turn off labels
for points of interest,
and I'm also going to
get rid of local roads.
Only in this map, not for real.
And then I'm going to choose
a darker color for the road
strokes remaining to make some
particular things stand out
more on the map.
Now it's important to note,
it's just a JSON blob,
so you can serve it from your
site or wherever you want,
and you can dynamically
restyle the map
without having to reload it.
No re-initialization necessary.
On JavaScript, it's as simple
as just calling the set options
and that's it.
And, of course, this is possible
across our range of platforms.
You never need to re-initialize
the map to change the style.
And it's really useful to
change the style at runtime,
because it allows you to
respond to user input.
To highlight different
things on your map.
We, in fact, built our
WYSIWYG wizard I just
showed you doing exactly this.
You play with the
sliders in the UI,
and the map is restyled
under the hood at runtime.
Let's take a look at
what this style will do.
Now we start with a normal map.
This is what my initialization
function gave me.
Any guesses what it'll look
like when I apply my style?
Yeah, I know, I'm the
one with the microphone.
Well.
I'll skip to it.
I've reduced it.
And it's pretty barren.
But it does really highlight the
highway on-ramps and off-ramps
in a way that can be
pretty useful if you're not
familiar with them.
You know, we can take
this further, too.
One of our most popular styles
is even more reductionist.
Here it is exemplified in our
transport track, a demo app,
which you might have seen
around I/O. This map has been
simplified so much
that it's just
the backdrop for some bold
foreground colors that really
highlight the
salient information.
But it still provides key,
useful geographical information
by being a map at a
level of granularity
that's useful to users.
Now if you want to go
the other direction,
you can change the
overall theme in a way
that's a little bolder.
Might catch the eye a bit more.
You can play with
these base colors
to match your UI or a theme.
You could do this
to match a brand
or to match a
particular time of day.
Here I've gone for,
I guess you could
call it, a strawberry mocha
kind of theme for my coffee shop
locator, complete with
custom icons for the markers.
I'm sure many of you could
come up with a better
style than this, and please do.
I'm looking forward to
more of your creations.
Now we can also do
styling beyond the map.
On Android, we now
support custom styles
for polygons and polylines.
These are really
useful for conveying
custom geographic information
in a visual format.
So, say if you're building
real-world infrastructure,
you can use styled
polygons and polylines
to indicate rollout progress
for internal stakeholders,
or for your end users to get a
feel for when your service will
reach them.
And you can put custom
icons on the polyline ends
to draw arrows, as well
as better differentiate
between different kinds of lines
with dots, dashes, thickness,
and color.
Bringing more styling
capabilities to our mobile APIs
is just the latest
example of the work
that we've been doing to give
you the same options across all
of our platforms.
We want to give you the
capabilities to succeed anyway.
So, with that, let's zoom
back out to review a little.
I did promise you documentation.
We've had a look at a few
of our Google Maps APIs
and how they can take
you beyond a regular map.
Our documentation for all
of these is right there
at developers.google.com/maps.
Hopefully very familiar
with those of you
who have already used it.
And in any case, where you just
need a quick and easy mapping
solution to round
out your offering,
we've shown how you can just
delegate that to the Google
Maps app using our Maps URLs.
And the documentation
for that is right there
at
developers.google.com/maps/URLs.
Now, of course,
none of this would
be possible without all of you.
And we're really looking forward
to hearing your feedback.
So please, if you've got bugs,
feature requests, suggestions,
or anything, we're going
to have Q&A. But also,
especially for those
of you watching online,
you can go to
developers.google.com/maps--
yes, it's a pattern--
/support, and you can see
our issue tracker there.
We do read this,
and we look forward
to seeing what you
have to say about it.
But while you're
still here, if you'd
like to learn more and
have a chat with us,
we do have office hours coming
up at 5:30 near the entrance.
And we're going to
have them 5:30 PM today
and again 8:30 AM tomorrow
for the early birds.
And right after
that, in the morning
tomorrow, we're going to
have our next location
and maps track sessions right
here again, from 9:30 AM,
with my friend Fontaine, and
10:30 AM, with my friend Ankur.
For all those of you
on the livestream
and on the recording, you
can find these sessions
by looking for them by name.
Now thank you all again for
coming here to join me today.
If you're shocked that
this is a bit short,
it's because I'm trying to
respect the fact that you're
still here after five.
Yeah, almost.
And all of you online, as well.
I hope you've
enjoyed the session
and learned something new.
And give our URLs and APIs a
try if you haven't already.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]